so this talk is going to cover three
different learning approaches and I'll
delve into each one I'm also going to
talk about getting connected with the
community and then I'll summarize
everything at the end so some things
that I'm not going to cover I'm not
gonna talk about boot camps I'm not
gonna talk about code schools I'm not
gonna talk about college or online
courses or how to find more tutorials so
the first one I'm going to talk about
challenge based learning what do I mean
by that there are lots of websites out
there that will give you lots of
different exercises you can do one at a
time and kind of grow your skills
through a small problem instead of
taking on something big
this style might have appeal to those
who don't want to start on a big project
don't want to build something from
scratch if you like rewards or trophies
or badges there's also that kind of a
motivation behind it and the another
thing that I really like about these is
most of them have pretty strongly
covered edge case testing so if you
think you solved it awesome you run the
test and you realize oh I missed
something so this is a very small list
of the quick Google search that I did
come up with all the different tools out
there there are a lot of them I think
I've played with three on this list some
things to keep in mind when you're
choosing a tool if you're wanting to
learn more than one language maybe today
you're learning Python but next month
you want to start learning JavaScript
try and pick a tool that's language
agnostic or that has multiple language
support inside of it so you're not
picking one tool for Python and then
having to find something else for
JavaScript or something else
as I mentioned strong solution testing
is really important they help you out
figure if you're if your code is not
optimized it's not running at speed or
if you missed an edge case things like
that
so having testing that gives you an
error message or something to go off of
is really helpful instead of just saying
I failed a lot of these tools have in
browser interpreters as well as editors
so if you're wanting to be on the go if
you don't have a dedicated laptop many
of them you can just work completely
online with them I mentioned badges
before so if you like reward mode
a lot of them have built-in review and
feedback mechanisms too so if you want
to get ideas on how to improve your code
or if you want to help others there's a
few that do that and many of them have
competitions so maybe you're not ready
to do a competition yet but they do host
them every month or every week so when
you feel a little bit more confident you
can join one of the competitions the
first one I'm going to talk about is
hacker rank so some things I liked about
hacker rank they have a pretty good
diversity of problems as well as
languages they support both Python 2 and
Python 3 the way they have things
grouped is from easy to advanced so
maybe you don't need to do the hello
world anymore you've figured that out on
your own
you can move on to something a little
bit more advanced maybe you haven't
played with strings as much yet or some
of the math related functions they also
have that in browser editor and
interpreter that I was talking about I
believe they have syntax highlighting
their tests run in real time so if you
hit you know submit my code check and
make sure it works
you get two watches each one passes or
fails and you'll get to see the error
messages of why it failed
maybe it wasn't optimized maybe you
missed an edge case some things that I
don't like about hacker rank they don't
have a community collaboration type of
built in when you submit your code you
submit it to be graded and then it's
lost in the ether so there's no hey you
could improve by doing this there's also
no way to take those problems offline or
test offline you have to do everything
through their website another one that
I've played with exorcism IO some things
I like about exorcism io completely
opposite of hacker rank they do have a
built-in review set when you submit your
code it goes public and anyone can make
comments on it or you can ask questions
and get help from others I think that's
really cool you might have done that one
way but there's a million other ways to
code something you can also join teams
or creative teams so maybe there's eight
of you all learning Python together and
you want to start tackling these
challenges you can post your code your
friends can help you figure out what you
wrong which you were missing where you
need to improve and you can grow
together something else I thought was
really cool their exercise list is
actually an open source github or an
open source repository on github so me
as an advanced engineer I might see that
oh this has a bug in it or I really
think that you should include this
exercise on your list and I can help
contribute and help them grow and what
they're they're offering their students
some things that were not my favorite it
is terminal command line dependent so if
you're not comfortable on the command
line yet they do walk you through how to
get set up and how to get started but
it's gonna be a little bit of a learning
curve or a barrier for entry there and
everything an exorcism IO you do run on
your computer there is no in browser
interpreter or test Runner or anything
else everything is run on your computer
in the command line or in the editor of
your choice and another thing that I ran
into maybe this is wrong but it seems
like I had to complete all of the
exercises in order so in order to get
exercise 2 to even look at it
I had to complete and get all of my
tests to pass for exit 4 exercise 1 from
a learning perspective that's probably a
good thing because it means if the next
exercise is building on a concept I
haven't just skipped over exercise one
just to get to 2 but I'm the type who
likes to skip around so not my cup of
tea as I said there are a bunch more
challenge based websites that kind of
fit this model so I've just covered -
there's lots more to explore pick one
that appeals to you or has a community
that you like so summarizing the
challenge based learning it's a great
way to build incrementally on a new
language the built-in test suite will
help you figure out what you've missed
what you need to fix the ones with built
in community are really helpful for
growing not only figuring out how to do
things but your coding style as well and
many of them do include competitions for
prizes money prizes physical prizes or
have jobs attached to them so if you
complete this challenge and do really
well you might get a job offer
so example based learning what I mean by
this is looking at someone else's code
and dissecting what they did and
understanding what they did and then
being able to take those concepts and
use them yourself so this is kind of
appealing for someone who needs some
starting point they're not ready to go
off and build on their own the exercise
approached and appeal to them but they
still want to be in code and learning if
you enjoy reading other people's code or
reading other people's stuff and kind of
seeing how they did things this is also
very appealing and if you if you've been
reading about a lot of abstract concepts
maybe you've read about decorators
recently but you've never seen one in
the wild you can go look at someone
else's code to see what that decorator
looks like and how it's running so
finding a project I do recommend that
you have at least a basic understanding
of github and git if you don't there's a
couple of tutorials I'll put on my last
slide that'll kind of help you get
started but you're going to need to find
things on github and then probably clone
them onto your local machine so things
to look for once you have that cloned or
once you've picked a project or when
you're picking a project excuse me does
it have a good read me does it have a
good like setup instructions you know
how to install to build it to run it
if there's no reaping this probably
isn't a repo for you it's an under
active development was the last commit
eight years ago that's probably not what
you want to play with it might be a date
it's probably broken avoid those if the
contributor is really responsive if
there are lots of issues being posted
and they're answering or they're doing
pull requests and trying to fix things
that's a really good sign as well if you
run into problems or have questions that
means that you can interact with them
and figure things out as well
the next one I'm gonna say is a little
bit more personal you'll it'll be up to
you what you call easy to read or follow
along with but I recommend you not dive
into something that's really complex for
you find something that you're gonna be
spending a lot of time in make sure that
you can follow along with what it's
doing and then don't be afraid to Google
for foreign words or terms if you've
never heard of PIP before most of these
repos if they're Python are gonna be
talking about pip so
oh maybe read about what that is things
to avoid if it's importing a hundred
outside packages and you've never heard
of any of them probably not what you
want to start with because then you're
gonna be researching those hundred
things before you even get to the code
you want to be reading if it's overly
complex if you're importing from this
file which is importing from this file
which is importing from this file and
this file and so on and so on if you
have to trace that long tree that's
gonna take a lot of time - probably not
something you want to get started in and
then if you don't even know where the
main file to start reading is don't
bother if you if there's not like a main
dot pie or something that says hey this
is where the code starts then I wouldn't
use that either so I've talked about how
to pick a project let's talk about
searching so if I'm gonna go on github
what kind of tools do I use I use slack
a lot my daily basis do they have
anything open-source that maybe I can
play around with I can search on github
and see I have a lot of friends or
engineers who are also doing various
open source projects various hobby
projects I could look at their github x'
to explore their repositories and I can
talk to them directly if I had run into
problems the most important thing I want
to say is find one that's interesting to
you and I don't just mean like the code
is interesting but the topic if you're
just starting out you're like everyone's
talking about machine learning I should
pick up a machine learning repository if
it's not a topic that you're interested
in chances are you're not gonna want to
spend the time to figure out what that
repository is even doing find something
yours is in I'm a crafter if there's a
knitting repository I'm gonna be so into
that so quick search and github for
slack narrowing down Python there's four
thousand results I can pick some sure
looks like we got some slack bots some
things that are doing something with the
API great those are things I can explore
once you've picked some repository to
start exploring and digging into some
ways to start breaking it down at a
macro level what is this code trying to
do is it a bot is it a web app is it a
command-line tool what is this what is
this repository doing overall and then
you need to kind of understand
how they're getting what they required
to do this I think importing from the
request library are they importing from
a file next door to this what's what's
going on to just generate the tools that
they need and then going into a more
micro level what is this code actually
doing what is this function doing what
is this line what does this code block
doing really digging in to understand
how this code is working and then asking
even more questions why did they write
it this way could you write it a
different way maybe instead of using a
for loop you could use a while loop here
so why don't you change it change the
one of the variable values change how
the function works see what happens and
if you throw an error message those are
the best because then you get to figure
out what happened and you get to learn
why it mattered that it was done the way
they had it written don't be afraid of
error messages they're really scary at
first I promise they're super fun maybe
that's a personal opinion and remember
you're not breaking their code by
changing all these and generating errors
it's not like their server is suddenly
going oh my god they hit all these type
errors something is wrong you're doing
all of this on your machine any changes
that you make or on your machine so
causes much chaos and havoc as you want
it's great once you're feeling a little
more confident in this repository you
feel like you've got it under control
see if there's any open issues that
someone has posted hey this was causing
a syntax error for me could you fix that
maybe while you were working with it you
were like you know I really wish it had
this feature see if you can build it out
and then when you're kind of done
playing with this repository what are
the takeaways that you found did you
learn some new third-party package had
you never used requests before but man
it's awesome did you get exposure to
some new built-ins maybe sets were new
to you and you'd never use them before
were there concepts that you hadn't seen
decorators or generators or some other
concept that you had heard about but
hadn't seen in the wild you can now use
those in a future project or at least
are less afraid of them so summarizing
for the example based learning find a
repository that's interesting to you
that you feel comfortable kind of
digging into
make sure to ask lots of questions of
the code how did they do this why did
they do this what happens if I change it
don't be afraid to cause all the error
messages again they're fun they teach
you what's what matters and why it's
wrong and then use what you learned so
project-based learning these are the
people who are like no I'm not into the
exercises I don't want to go play anyone
elses code I want to build my own thing
and they're ready to get started from
scratch so if you already have a project
in mind maybe you have that blog that
you've been meaning to get started and
of course you should build it yourself
so let's do this if you couldn't find a
good example on github maybe no one was
using the slack API quite the way you
want to so you're gonna build your own
thing it's really appealing for those
who are very self-motivated and very
goal-oriented if you're the project
planner who lights you know creating
Kanban boards this is for you and if
you're a junior engineer in your career
and you're trying to interview it places
creating a portfolio building things
from scratch that way is really good you
can show them off to future employers so
my biggest piece of advice scope creep
if you've never heard of scope creep
it's when you start off with this little
tiny concept and then it just balloons
out so you're gonna build an email
server great all you need to do is send
or receive emails but wouldn't folders
be nice and wouldn't filtering be really
cool and what about Auto forwarding and
then it just keeps going so to help kind
of manage scope creep as well as kind of
build out how you should do this project
I recommend breaking everything down
into two do's and it to do can be
anything from research a new package or
a new concept experimenting with how
that package works actually writing the
code for a certain file or function
documenting everything you've been doing
writing the readme or the setup to make
sure that anyone else who comes along
and plays with your repository can
actually run it and then building tests
as well so all of those can be to do's
and they can be broken out even more if
you feel yourself getting discouraged I
once wrote a project ahead of thousand
lines of code and didn't test any of it
and then I was like I should break tests
that one giant to do of tests was
looming over me I hated it so I broke it
down into even smaller pieces I was like
alright first I'm gonna test this file
and it wasn't as daunting then I only
had 100 lines of code to test instead of
a thousand and it felt really good to
kind of say hey I finished this one and
I felt like I accomplished something it
kept my momentum going and it kept me
interested in what I was doing so I made
sure to celebrate each success any time
I finished one of those to do is I was
like I am awesome and if you get stuck
or if you trigger those error messages
we were talking about Google is your
friend I have typed in an exact stack
trace into Google before and been
absolutely thrilled with the wonderful
results that I get because everyone else
does it - they're like I got this what
does it mean Stack Overflow there's
usually a great conversation yeah so
Google's great stack trace stack trace
messages and Google super great I'm
gonna tangent slightly and talk about my
passion project slash horror story I got
really addicted to this board game
called Castle dice and I was like I know
I'm gonna make this into a web app
because all of my friends are moving
away and I love playing this so much
wouldn't it be great if we could just
log in and play together yes this is
what I will do
so castle dice had three decks of cards
it had five different types of dice it
had five different trackers it had a
board of over here and a board for
tracking over here and a third board for
tracking more things and there were
turns and rounds and people involved
anyway super fun game I recommend it to
everyone the complexity though for
coding this a little more than I should
have been enough so I started breaking
it down I was like you know I've got
these five types of dice and each die
has six eyes but they're not won 2-6 cuz
there's a cow there's a barbarian
there's a one stone and a two stone and
then that dice deals with gold and not
stone okay so I need to figure out how
to store these how am I going to
randomize the roll what happens if I
need to add the diced
so there were lots of to do is on my
plate not to mention the decks and the
tractors and everything else so did I
finish it not not at all not at all but
I do go back to it every 6 to 12 months
and for me I wrote this five years ago
it's kind of interesting to see how my
code is progressed and I keep coming up
with more ideas about how to fix it how
to change it how to improve it and there
are small things that work it's just not
the full game that's fine that's totally
fine
so my my lessons after playing with
castle dice it was a huge project
and it was definitely something that I
shouldn't have chosen as my first yeah
I'm gonna break away and learn Django uh
there were a lot of things that I still
don't really know how to approach I
never studied game theory so I'm still
trying to figure out how I can do you
take a turn and now it'll tell me I've
taken a turn and then it will tell the
next person anyway that'll be the next
month thing to play with I did learn a
lot though this was the first time that
I had built a randomizer to roll this
dice and do some stuff I think it was
the first time I built like I an
object-oriented class I was super proud
of it I'm still vaguely proud of it and
it didn't actually matter whether or not
I completed it because sure I didn't
build the whole game but I didn't know
the dice roller and so you could click a
button and watch the dice like change
sides and roll and give you different
values and I got to show that off in an
interview and I was embarrassed that I
didn't finish the whole thing but they
were really impressed to see that I had
something working and that they could
look at my code so that's kind of cool
too it didn't matter that it wasn't
finished
so to summarize choose something small
and break it into smaller tasks Stack
Overflow and Google awesome I consider
everything a work in progress
if you ask me about Castle dice your
last commit is two years ago are you
sure it's not an abandoned project no I
will come back to this I promise I
promise I'm gonna finish it
someday and the biggest thing make sure
you're having fun this is a project that
you chose to build yours
so keep it fun don't be discouraged
so getting connected with community
we've talked about all these different
ways that you can do code but getting
into the community is what I find is
really helpful because there are people
even here today who if I go up and say
you know I'm really struggling with this
Python thing chances are they at least
know what Python is right pretty sure
they're either using it in their daily
jobs or they have used it in a daily job
or they're on some open-source project
or some hobby project or they're just
learning it like me or not like me
currently but anyways so coming to these
community events you have lots of
options to not only network but also get
advice and guidance on things that maybe
you're struggling with or that you need
some help with and then you need a new
resource new Docs whatever it's also a
great place to find a mentor so I love
mentoring
I hope I'm good at it I think I'm good
at it I should talk to my mentees
mentors will both help and encourage you
so they're not just going to hand you
the answer really good mentors will
coach you to the solution they want you
to be able to think through the problem
yourself and not just be handed the
solution they want to make sure that you
can come up with it on your own the next
time and understand why that's the the
correct answer and we also really care
about your growth like I have a mentor I
really love it when my mentee has been
struggling with something and she
finally has this click moment or the
code finally stops triggering an error
and she calls me up she's like oh my god
it finally works yes I just want to
celebrate with her that's that's
something that I get to enjoy as a
mentor I have helped her through this
process I have coached her and now I get
to enjoy the fruits of her labor not
take credit for them but at least enjoy
them with her so there's lots of groups
conferences tech events all kinds of
things out there these are the handful
that I have been to or are aware of PI
ladies lunch was awesome today by the
way there are lots of Python meetups
Gengo meetups flasks meetups if you're
more into the conference scene PyCon
north bay Python which you may have
heard of
hi babe there's lots of Python specific
things even if I just go to meetup.com
and type in Python in San Francisco cuz
that's where I live there's a ton of
results and these are just the groups
they're not even the events if you're
into other languages there's waffle je s
in the Bay Area I know there's donut je
s in Portland
there's railsbridge hackerspace I think
is more agnostic there's lots of ways to
find interactive communities if you are
of the female or non-binary persuasion
there's also PI ladies like I mentioned
but girl geek dinners are really great
networking opportunities women who code
has a great newsletter they also do
events group of girl develop it does I
think JavaScript courses but I think
they also do events and if you're the
type who lives in the boondocks middle
of nowhere you're like I'm not near a
metropolitan area how am I gonna do
anything there are tons of online
communities as well pi ladies has their
own slack Exorcism IO that I talked
about has a built-in community platform
so you're able to interact and get
feedback anyways so to summarize my
summaries of summaries we covered
challenge based learning so practicing
with small exercises taking advantage of
the test cases when they do and don't
fail community feedback competitions all
the things baked into that example based
learning so digging into someone else's
code and really understanding how it
works why it works what breaks asking
questions
playing with error messages we talked
about project base breaking a large idea
down into smaller pieces preferably
avoiding the large idea in the first
place getting help with that putting
things into a sack overflow and Google
when you run into problems and having
fun like all of these that is the most
important part we also talked about
community various events finding a
mentor so the biggest takeaway I want
you to have today is there's no one
right way to continue your learning
journey maybe one of these really
resonated with you maybe you hate all of
these ideas that's great don't take my
word for it some of these have worked
for me some of them have not some have
worked at certain times and
not so pick your own path your own
journey and then here are all the
resources again I work at honor my
Twitter is Kate Curran Holly I did
manage to post these slides on github
right before this talk and then some
other links that I talked about so thank
you
[Applause]